what's the shittiest place you went to
so kinshasa
democratic republic of congo is about as
shitty as the world again worse than
portland because we have a only
at least portland has beer shout out to
will
yeah that's an inside joke between only
five of us so
i ask people all the time like if you
had millions of dollars and you were
quote unquote chilling what do you want
to do with your free time everyone says
travel the world but nobody wants to go
to shitty places you had this yearning
to see the worst of the worst of the
worst hairy armpits hairy armpits so you
could sort of codify your love for
america how did that even resonate with
your mind it wasn't necessarily
codifying so when i was with the air
force academy they sent me to china so i
was on a i was learning chinese and in
2002 2002 i went to china to do a
six-week language immersion with the
with the air force academy and when i
was there
it was i've been to canada i'd been to
resorts in mexico like i've done the
stuff that most americans do but in
china
i was eating dog
i was really i could yeah it's a it's a
normal meat to eat there what about bat
i didn't have bat that's less than
normal yeah yeah you were eating dogs
yeah we ate we ate dog meat right we
there are there are stands street stalls
just like you would get a hot dog in new
york really with scorpions and like uh
different large beetles like this is
just normal stuff there right and then
it's it looks like new york but the food
stalls are not anything like we've ever
seen i can't drink the water the water
out of the sink can't be used to brush
your teeth the water that comes out of a
water fountain when you go to a
restaurant you always have to ask for
the bottles of water like these were
little things where i was like i don't
have to do this in america like i can
literally go to any sink in the united
states
and like grab a glass and drink some
water yeah it might taste bad but it's
not actually going to give me a
long-term permanent gastrointestinal
issue yeah you're not going to have
montezuma's revenge yeah so just these
things when i when i finally left china
to come back to the united states and i
landed in the united states i was like
oh this feels good so why would you want
more of that and even worse because one
thing that i've always been is very
proud of of my country and it gives me
the ability to drown out the noise
there's so much noise in our country so
much what i call first world problems
people bitching and complaining and
fighting
about things that give that make us inc
a half a percent point zero one percent
better or worse than where we were
yesterday not realizing we're 35 percent
better than other first world countries
i took my executive assistant with me on
a trip recently to
uh to
austria and we went to australia to
support like ukrainian refugee program
or whatever else
it was awesome excellent food excellent
booze excellent people beautiful
surroundings the buildings were pristine
very very heavily socialist country
right we come back to the united states
we cross the border in orlando you know
what she says
it's so good to be back in america
i was like [ __ ] yes that is exactly
right that's why you want to travel the
world you're just going to get to that
conclusion a whole lot faster in third
world countries than in first that is a
very good point by the way especially as
a uh
uh i saw your you you you and your uh
daughter your
daughter right and you have a daughter
yep you and your daughter were sitting
there she was doing homework or studying
world or wars or different things and
just watching how you're raising your
kid as well
uh have you taken your your daughter yet
to a third world world country and if
yes which one was it so my children have
not been to a third world country
they've they've lived in the united arab
emirates they lived in abu dhabi got it
for a year got it um and my son
especially they both have very fond
memories and uae is a first world
country because it's a khaliji arab
country
rich in oil wealth yeah they basically
overnight developed into a first world
country so it's not a difficult life at
all it's except for the heat
and
the culture right arab culture is a
difficult culture when you're westerner
my kids have very fond memories but they
also are like it's not like like i don't
want to go back to uae this is something
they tell me often i don't want to go
back to the desert i like the fact that
i can you know be free to talk to
whoever i want to talk to i don't have
to worry if they're a girl or a boy i
don't have to worry about classes
they're saying that at what age
my son is nine my daughter is fine i
love that so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]